in the end it's about the movies
themselves it doesn't matter what they
cost to make or how much they made it
the box-office it's about the power of
their storytelling and the power of
their ideas only one of tonight's
nominees will win the Oscar for Best
Picture but they will live on because
they touch something and all who saw
them here are the nominees for Best
Picture American sniper Birdman or the
unexpected virtue of ignorance boyhood
the grand budapest hotel
the imitation game Selma
a theory of everything whiplash
you
and the Oscar goes to
who gave this son-of-a-bitches green
card Birdman
you
I don't want to talk
oh my god they want me to talk because
I'm the worst english-speaking guy here
maybe next year the government will
inflict some immigration rules to the
Academy to Mexicans in a role that
suspicious I guess I want to thank so
many people that I forgot also meaning
our non red Western again I think thank
you very much for believing in this
crazy idea all the people that was B
were before it behind this story before
I mean behind this film was really
heroes because the idea was really crazy
a script that started with a middle-aged
man interior dressing room cross leg
floating can go anywhere and we are here
I don't know how that happened but it
happened and anyway I just really want
to thank anybody everybody and I want to
thank Christina my kids Emma and Joe I
want to thank our agents Brian rogue
Beth everyone who helped get this movie
made it's amazing she's reminding me my
wife Marie I love you you know that okay
we said that every morning when we wake
up
honestly and my kids but anyway there
are so many people to think
I want to thank tears Gallagher which is
a widower Raymond Carver who allow us to
use the Raymond Carver story which is
incredible I want to thank you Guillermo
del Toro and Alfonso Cuaron as I
mentioned already because they have been
part of these two all my life in my
career and I don't know if you have
something to say you want to take the
opportunity Michael I want to say
Michael and all the cast but Michael was
a guy who really really Michael fun this
has been a tremendous experience I this
guy the this bold is bold can be and it
was just a tremendous honor for media
look it's great to be here
Who am I kidding this is just great fun
thank you very much finally finally I
just want to I want to take one second I
just want to take opportunity I want to
dedicate this award for for my fellow
Mexicans the ones who live in Mexico I
pray that we can find and build the
government that we deserve and the ones
that live in this country who are part
of the latest generation of immigrants
in this country is pray that they can be
treated with the same dignity and
respect of the ones who came before and
build this incredible immigrant nation
thank you very much